where are some of the fun places we
might visit first in a semi-permanent
way inside the solar system that you
think are worth visiting yeah at the end
of 500 years i'm hoping we make the big
launch towards another solar system
really driven by the fact that we
now actually have exoplanets that we
know we might be able to get to and
survive on whereas 20 years ago we
really had almost none certainly none
that we knew were habitable
and exoplanets even just just discovered
didn't start to happen until 89 and
really the early 90s for the real
validated ones so you know
i'm hoping over the next 500 years we go
from thousands of possible habitable
plants to hundreds of thousands or
millions
you know especially with some of the
recent telescopes launch we'll find them
but but before we get there
i have a a whole section i really
describe about the magic of titan
because it has all this methane which is
a great hydrocarbon you can use to make
fuel you can use it it's cold as all
bejesus on titan but if you get ice it's
uh yes it's what so what's a titan made
up of what is titan oh everybody loves
titan yeah it is it's a favorite uh it's
this kind of eerie uh green hued moon um
that's around saturn that is
uh
into our knowledge
you know this large it has like you know
it's so cold it has these methane lakes
where the methane normally is a gas but
there would actually be so cold it's
like a lake of methane you could go
swimming in it potentially there might
be some degree of uh rocks or maybe
mountains there but they might also be
made of like frozen methane so
no one's ever no person's obviously been
there but it is you know have enough
satellite imagery and some data that you
could actually potentially survive on
titan so i think that'd be one place
where i'm hoping that we would at least
have
a bit of an outpost it might not be a
luxurious retreat because it's really
cold is there a life on titan you think
underneath the surface somewhere maybe
well actually with all that carbon and
all those hydrocarbons it is very
possible that some microbial life could
be there and hanging out waiting for us
to to dip our toes into the methane and
find it
but we don't know yet but i think that's
one place i'd like to see an outpost i
would like to see other outposts near
jupiter but jupiter has extremely high
radiation actually so even places like
io which are volcanically active and
quite amazing
we probably couldn't survive that long
that close to jupiter though it has
because it brings such a giant planet
uh it emits back out a lot of radiation
that's collecting from other parts of
the universe and it juts back out so if
you get too close to jupiter it'd
actually almost certainly not be able to
survive depending on which part of it
but
that's one risk about jupiter um but
it'd be cool to see the giant red spot
uh up close maybe have some spots there
mars stop one
then you get to pick titan or io so ice
firing ice
the robert frost poem comes to mind yeah
and then europa is that you would be
cool too and enceladus which is a big
ocean it might be there like an alien
ocean that's under the uh it might be
even water ice that's there and why even
liquid water potentially there under the
surface so that'd be a great candidate
the asteroids of ceres would be good or
eros or big enough you get a little bit
of gravity
that it'd be interesting you could you
know have maybe a habitable place there
and they just might be big enough that
you could get there survive and even
have a tiny bit of gravity but not much
why do you like asteroids no are you
just this we're just listing vacations
yeah vacation spots basically yes i'd
say well so they probably have a lot of
rare earth minerals that you could use
for manufacturing which is why
part of the space economy that's being
built up now is people really want to go
and hollow out the asteroids and bring
back all the
um you know all the resources from it so
this uh legally is very possible because
even though um
the space space act prevents people from
militarizing space or owning all of it
if you get the resources out of an
asteroid but you don't actually say you
own it that's still that's perfectly
legal